hi I'm Eric Voss and as we still try to
recover from Game of Thrones season
seven one big theory a lot of you guys
are asking about is bran the knight came
basically Willebrand stark uses
abilities to see through time and
influence past events to work into the
body of the first man who became the
knight gained thousands of years ago get
trapped in that body and then become the
night king that we know and fear today
I'm gonna quickly explain this theory
and all the interesting evidence for it
why it's gaining traction and my
personal take on all this and by the way
I'm gonna mention some stuff that
happens in the season 7 finale so
spoiler warning if you haven't watched
it yet
and don't worry yes the finale breakdown
is on its way and if it's not already
out by the time you're watching this
editors are currently working on it I
can see them please hurry
okay okay sorry sorry okay here we go
okay so the theory is that bran Stark
will and has already used his powers to
try to prepare Westeros is past for the
war with the others the White Walkers
remember bran did use his abilities to
warg into hodor's body in the past to
save himself in the future and according
to the previous three-eyed Raven game of
thrones' explanation for this type of
time-travel is that it's predestined
that it was always meant to be this way
so when you look at it that way bran
technically didn't change anything when
he effected hodor's mind in the past but
rather Hodel was always going to have
that particular seizure and wake up
mumbling the words hold the door in to
Hodor and bran merely fulfilled that
step in both of their destinies so this
theory is that bran in the future will
do a similar thing with the knight king
after multiple failed attempts at using
his abilities to influence the past in
other ways so here's where this theory
merges previous brand time-travel
theories that we brought up before first
bran projected himself to King Aerys the
second to the Mad King speaking to him
as a whisper in the wind kind of like
how he did with his father at the Tower
of joy now in this case bran will have
tried to convince Aerys to produce and
store quantities of wildfire to defend
the realm against the White Walkers
urging him to quotes burned them all but
then these whispers would have driven
the mad
mad causing him to instead use the
wildfire to burn up his political
enemies and plunge the realm into
rebellion so after that first attempt
fails ran according to the theory we'll
go back a second time 8000 years earlier
right after the long night the last time
the White Walkers descended from the far
north at this point bran could influence
his ancestor and his namesake Brandon
Stark bran the Builder the founder of
House Stark that Brandon famously
oversaw the construction of the wall
using the help of giants and the magic
of the children of the forest with the
whole goal of keeping the White Walkers
out now it's even possible that our
brand could actually be that Brandon
legend says that bran the Builder began
constructing even as a young boy and as
we've seen before when bran projects
himself into the past he can walk but as
we just saw in this past season finale
that major defense measure eventually
epically failed to stop the night King
from advancing so that will lead to
brands third attempt to influence the
past by war gained into one of the first
men during the war between the children
of the forest and the first men the
thing that led to the White Walkers and
trying to convince them to never create
the White Walkers to begin with and
according to the theory the children of
the forest won't recognize this first
man will view him as a threat and
instead taken captive and go through
with their plans anyway to convert him
into this supernatural weapon it's at
this point when bran will get trapped
inside this body and lose himself member
that's a possibility that bran has been
warned about before in season four Jojen
Reed cautioned bran against war gained
into summers mind for too long it's
tempting if you'll trap to someone
particularly you'll forget what it was
to be human then in season six the
previous three-eyed raven repeated this
wisdom
we need to see but if you stay too long
you drown and then in the episode after
that the three-eyed Raven said this I
told you many times stay too long where
you don't belong
now there are a few key parallels
between bran and the night king for one
both characters appeared to be green
seers they know when future events will
happen remember the night king knew
where bran was going to be when he
marked him some people have even said
the characters do look similar
when brand projects into the past his
doublet does kind of match the night
Kings at least it would probably feel
awkward both showing up to the same
party wearing that and ever since
they've cast a new actor to play the
night king and are using more makeup and
prosthetics on his face instead of CGI
an actor's nose does have a similar
shape to brands nose but I would say
perhaps most interestingly there was the
specific direction of the night Kings
creation scene notice how when Leif
approached the man with the dagger the
camera cuts back to bran as he clings to
the roots of the weirwood tree almost as
if he himself is bracing for some kind
of pain and then later in that scene
when Leif explains to brand what he just
witnessed
notice how bran is posed against the
weirwood roots just like the night king
was with Leif bearing down on him okay
this theory has some very interesting
implications one if it were true it
would give new meaning to the three-eyed
Ravens promise to bran at the end of
season 4 you'll never walk again but you
will live now at the time the assumption
was that that meant brand would be the
next three-eyed Raven or that he could
warg into a dragon or maybe fly through
time but now if this theory is true it
could refer to the night king flying on
the back of his resurrected bazarian
also this could explain why brands
rapid-fire visions in season 6 included
this particular shot of a dragon's
shadow over King's Landing of all of
those images this is the only one that
remains kind of unexplained so this
could be from midnight Kings perspective
as he eventually flies bazarian over the
capital but really now that it seems
like the final battle of Game of Thrones
will be this one-on-one combat between
champions Jon Snow is the champion of
men and may be champion to the Lord of
Light and the night king is the champion
of the army of the Dead
this would pit John again
brand giving this battle even more
emotional stakes oh now hold on your
butts cuz we got a big but coming
let's back in the but here's a but oh
that's a that's a massive but now let's
wake up from this vision come back to
reality for a second animates while this
is a very interesting theory all logic
in my brain says that this is probably
not the case I mean let's face it this
theory is pretty loosely based on
conjecture in coincidence like lots of
people wear doublet sand Game of Thrones
skies and there are probably lots of
green seers and wargs in this world a
lot of people I that knows but mostly I
have two bigger Hang Ups with this the
one this still wouldn't explain any more
about what the night King wants why he's
evil to begin with like I think that
mystery is a big reason why this theory
is so popular we still don't know [ __ ]
about the night King and what the White
Walkers goals are by the way I actually
went into a different theory about that
a few months ago it involves the
children the forest and the Isle of
faces on the gods I I still think that
could be true but brand getting trapped
inside the night king for thousands of
years doesn't tell us what caused a
night King to originally want to kill
humans and use their body parts to make
gang symbols and raise an army of the
Dead whoever that is
that's not brand that's somebody else
and who is that we still wouldn't know
my second hang-up is I just don't think
Game of Thrones is gonna spend its final
seven episodes dealing with complicated
time travel mythology Game of Thrones is
not a show about time travel it's a show
about violent medieval war games with
supernatural elements that's designed to
make us to okay with incest and I think
if the writers wanted to go down that
time-travel rabbit hole more there
probably would have been some other
moment since they hold the door episode
that showed brand projecting himself
through time more actively trying to
meddle with things and influence events
all to better establish how exactly time
travel works in this universe instead
notice how they've kind of moved on from
hold the door now making brand more of a
witness to these events now I know there
is a neatness to believing that brand
Stark is responsible for all these major
historical events but bear in mind that
would also take away responsibility from
all these characters which would
contradict George RR Martin's main
agenda with the ax Song of Ice and Fire
series
what would a medieval fantasy look like
if it truly reflect
rulers from history many of whom were
yes ad paranoid cruel impulsive
traitorous foolish superstitious noble
to a fault and yeah super incestuous
however I don't think hold the door was
just gonna be a one-off moment either I
still think that that moment was
symbolically opening the door for brands
powers to play a more active role in
this endgame and yes I do think that
includes revealing that brand will and
perhaps already has influenced past
events in some other way but I predict
like hold the door it's gonna be a more
emotionally cathartic event that ties
into the characters and the themes of
the show rather than just some mind that
leaves everyone confused for example
I've said this before but I still think
it's possible that brand grows old to
become the same three-eyed Raven whom he
met under the tree projecting back to
himself in the past constantly and his
younger broken self and to unlocking his
inner strength and playing a role in the
wars to come me personally that would
close the loop of brand's character arc
and keep his story self-contained other
than that I think the real function of
brand's time travel abilities will
continue to be the primary way the show
has already used it so far to revisit
these key moments from Westeros is
history that characters need to see to
motivate their present goals a tower of
joy Liana and Rhaegar secret wedding
bran repeating the Littlefinger that
quote chaos is a ladder I think that
approach is far more dramatically
resonant and much truer to the kind of
show Game of Thrones is which constantly
features characters echoing past
conversations following the footsteps of
leaders from the past and trying to
escape their shadows do you think brand
could be the night king or do you think
it's more likely that he could be some
other character like the three-eyed
Raven also what other past events do you
want to see bran revisit in season 8 the
backstory of Westeros is filled with
amazing events that I'd love to see
battle the Trident
the tourney at Harrenhal the burning of
summerhall Aegon's conquest go on let
your imagination fly down in the
comments below or tweet me Eddie a vos
or at new rockstars at new rockstars and
yeah keep an eye out for my even more
in-depth breakdown of the finale
episodes and if you like you can help us
make more of these Theory videos by
contributing to us on patreon big thanks
to all of our donors especially Kelly
hopper alright thanks for watching bye